we're told all the time about science
what if what happened when our public
health experts like dr fauci for
instance told us not to wear masks don't
wear masks masks are bad for you if you
wear a mask you're being irresponsible
surgeon general of the united states
said the same thing and we were told
trust the science believe the science
as though the science was some deity
that we have to pay obeisance to
well then all those guys completely
changed their minds based on what based
on new studies we didn't get really new
studies
they change their minds then you've got
to believe the science there we were
told believe the science 15 days to slow
the spread flatten the curve
so that you don't overwhelm the hospital
system not find a cure not reduce the
number of cases
not even really reduce the number of
deaths just reduce the number of
unnecessary deaths if you were to
overwhelm the hospital system
we never came close to overwhelming the
hospital system anywhere
in the country including new york they
had the javits center they had that
hospital ship didn't need either of them
same thing over in california didn't
need it great big success right
so the lockdowns are over by april 1st
right
no way not a chance we're now 241 days
in people are dying alone
people are not seeing their grandparents
now we're being told we're not allowed
to go home for thanksgiving
or if we do go home you can only have a
meal with 10 people so
if you know i've got some catholic
friends of mine some of them have just
10 kids or 11 kids or 12 kids so you got
to you got to pick your favorites
you got to send those other kids outside
they're not maybe they can come for
christmas we'll see
we'll see if president-elect joe biden
will let them
more on him in just a bit so there's one
new machine out of nebraska
which is it's an it's a new scientific
way to circumvent the lockdowns
it allows you to hug i can't even get
through it without laughing
it allows you to hug your relatives
by by reaching through a plastic
sheet and and in plastic wrapping your
plastic
arms around your beloved grandfather
take a listen
[Music]
something kind of heartwarming because
you know that these grandparents haven't
seen their grandkids in however long
it's also very sad
this is great
this this is what not the virus has
reduced this to
this is what bad policies have reduced
us to this is
inhuman but you know i i have uh
friends i unfortunately haven't been
able to travel back to see my
grandparents in the last
whatever five or six months that this
has really been going on
but i have friends who have and in some
cases
the the parents didn't want to see them
they said i'm too afraid of the virus
but in most cases the grandparents said
come on in here sonny
this happened to a very good friend of
mine just a couple months ago
he said come on in here i know i'm 85
years old i know i'm at risk but you
know i'm going to die soon anyway and i
don't want to go
without seeing my loved ones there have
been petitions in nursing there was a
protest actually at a nursing home
where people said the thing we look
forward to is getting hugs from our
relatives and you're taking that away
from us
you sick politicians
that question of whether or not you can
hug your grandparents that's not a
scientific question
maybe there's some increased risk to the
virus maybe the risk actually isn't
that large compared to other other
viruses that's sort of beside the point
there's a political question a
philosophical question
a theological question what are we here
for how are we to relate to one another
how are we to
relate to life how are we to relate to
death
it occurred to me yesterday that covid
is the single craziest thing to ever
happen in my lifetime
ever not the virus we've had plenty of
viruses in my lifetime
west nile ebola all those sort of things
swine flu
the loc the kovid lockdowns that's the
craziest thing to happen in my lifetime
i tweeted this out and a number of
people said well what about 9 11 you
were alive for 9 11.
9 11 i guess was the most horrific thing
to happen in my lifetime
but that's different than crazy it's not
that it was so crazy so unusual so
unexpected so unprecedented there have
always been terrorist attacks
in history many of them have come from
islamic radicals there actually was
already a terror attack on the world
trade center in 1993.
the people who did it told us their
justification for doing it so still
obviously horrific crazy is a different
thing
and the covid lockdowns are absolutely
crazy because there is
no reasoning behind it
they change the reasoning every single
day they extend it
indefinitely there is no end in sight no
matter what these hack politicians tell
you
biden's covet advisor says four to six
weeks a likely story i've heard that one
before
to quote a former president fool me once
shame on you fooled me twice
the point is you ain't gonna fool me
again
that's the sort of science that we're
talking about here
it's just a power grab i hope you
enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you